(energetic drum music)
- [Narrator] Mastering an
instrument can take years,
but not for this drumming prodigy.
- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story was made possible by LEGO.
Play Her Way.
(drumstick tapping)
Nine year-old Yoyoka Soma
took the internet by storm
when a video of her playing
drums to a Led Zeppelin cover
went viral in 2018.
♪ Still don't seem to care ♪
- [Narrator] And today, she
has no plans of slowing down.
- [Narrator] Yoyoka is the
drummer in her family's band.
They perform all across Japan.
(audience cheers)
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh oh ♪
(dramatic drum music)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Aside from
playing with her family,
Yoyoka's talent has been
internationally recognized.
(Ellen laughing)
(electronic tone chimes)